avec nous sur ce plateau pour en parler
jean didier berthault conseillère à la
mairie de paris dans le 17ème
arrondissement vous êtes l'un des porte
parole de xavier bertrand candidat à la
présidentielle bonsoir jean didier
berthault merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés thomas porte parole national de
génération s merci à vous d'être là
aussi bon soir thomas porte alors
emmanuel macron qui a donc parlé de
santé et d'économie de social de
géopolitique un petit peu hier soir un
mot tout d'abord un sur son discours car
le travail était hier soir à bram ans au
coeur de ses préoccupations il a parlé
emploi et surtout de réforme de
l'assurance surnage vous propose de
l'écouter
pôle emploi passera en revue les
centaines de milliers d'offres d'emploi
disponibles sans réponse dès les
prochaines semaines les demandeurs
d'emploi qui ne démontreront pas une
recherche active verront leurs
allocations suspendues
alors c'est important de faire entendre
cette phrase parce que ça c'est plutôt
un thème clairement à droite il vous
piquent un nouveau thème la droite en
rêvait manuel macro le fait ou va le
faire on sait pas trop on vivait berton
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il ya deux
français illustre qui sont revenus de
l'espace il ya thomas pesquet ya le
président de la république c'est
absolument incroyable
d'entendre un discours comme on a pu
l'entendre pendant plus de 20 minutes
qui n'était absolument pas consacré
d'ailleurs à la situation sanitaire pas
plus que cinq minutes pour ensuite
développer des thèmes de campagne pour
le président est en campagne tout le
monde l'a compris maintenant sa
crédibilité pour nous annoncer trois
mois avant les élections ce qu'il n'a
pas fait pendant cinq ans tout le monde
aura compris qu'elle est très limité
alors on a entendu à gauche
on avait tendance à avoir envie de
conseiller à mâcon de rejoindre les
leurs c'est votre avis aussi thomas
porte vous avez fait des bonds sur votre
canapé hier soir devant votre télé mais
pas des bons mais ça a confirmé la ligne
politique d' emmanuel macron qui est
celle de s'attaquer aux plus précaires
et vous avez parlé de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage on doit voir le
président qui disait ce qu'il a dit à
l'époque c'est-à-dire traverser la rue
pour trouver un emploi c'est un
président en campagne qui hier a fait un
discours de campagne alors que
l'allocution était prévu sur les mesures
sanitaires et la gestion de la crise de
duke au vide on a eu trois mots
là-dessus et pas un mot sur l'hôpital
public d'ailleurs que dans une situation
absolument une catastrophe et ici il a
dit qu'il avait fait un maximum pour les
soignants
jamais on n'avait fait autant pour
justement
il ya aussi un sujet sur l'intervention
du chef de l'état puisque hier c'était
un discours de candidat et on avait
personne pour le contredire il comprit
pas de journaliste pour lui poser des
questions sauf qu'il maniait le
maquereau ans et 4 milliard en moins
dans le budget de l'hôpital public
depuis 2010 est cédée soignants
bout'chou face et des fermetures de lits
y compris pendant le coït donc voilà ce
que c'est emmanuel macron et la
politique de santé mais hier c'était un
discours à droite mais c'est un
président de droite donc il est cohérent
avec ce qu'il porte depuis le début de
son quinquennat jean didier berthault au
même analyse que thomas porte finalement
il n'a pas tellement évolué emmanuel
macron il était de droite à l'origine
et toujours autant dans ce qu'il était
c'est une évolution si l'essai de droite
ils obtiendraient des résultats et est
ce que je ressens surtout dans le led
son intervention d'hier c'est une erreur
aussi par rapport à la stratégie de
lutte contre la pandémie ce qui est
important pour nous aujourd'hui en
france face à cette reprise potentielle
de la pandémie c'est obtenir des
résultats sur la vaccination c'est avoir
de la clarification sur le pass
sanitaire c'est effectivement avoir des
mesures sur l'hôpital public et
aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas hier soir
on n'a pas eu ça on a eu des mesures qui
était politique et qui peuvent aller
même à contre sens du résultat espéré
parce que si vous êtes par exemple
contre le nucléaire est ce que vous
allez vous faire vacciner par rapport à
la parole présidentielle est ce qu'il
n'ya pas une confusion dans tout ça est
ce que finalement le but le but
recherché n'est pas l' inverse du
résultat obtenu alors on va on va
regarder les premières réactions sur le
pont télégramme daté france la première
qui nous dit mais de notre on veut
séduire une partie de la droite on le
voit bien il fit les idées des élèves se
doit vous faire plaisir on attend son
allocution lundi prochain après le
deuxième débat leur est effectivement
vous pensez vraiment qu'il est votre
programme de nuit en tout cas on voit
visiblement qu'il se nourrit des idées
donc c'est très bien on apporte des
idées au pays on les appliquera et c'est
pour ça que j'attends après chaque débat
une âme une allocution du président
maintenant alors deuxième remarque mais
la nuit qui nous dit la gauche aux
fraises la droite dans le peloton de
tête en tout cas dans les sondages
macron pas folle la guêpe en gros est ce
qu il a à ce que c'est pas finalement
assez malin de la part du président de
la république aujourd'hui de se
positionner à droite pour l'aide
siphonné une nouvelle fois et tenter de
remporter cette présidentielle thomas
porte ça vous inquiète à gauche
j'imagine quand même ça nous inquiète
pas parce que c'est que j'ai dit au
départ emmanuel macron
les mène une politique de droite depuis
qu'il a été élu et aujourd'hui il
continue de mener cette politique là et
je crois que l'on est calme dans un pays
aujourd'hui qui traverse une crise
économique sanitaire et sociale d'une
ampleur inégalée on était aujourd'hui
c'est la journée mondiale de la
précarité énergétique on a 12 millions
de précaires énergie et le président
emmanuel macron hier à cibler les
chômeurs à simuler les jeunes comme si
ces gens là étaient responsables de leur
propre situation moi je vous rappelle
une chaussure les chômeurs parce qu'on
les a montrées beaucoup du doigt hier et
gabriela talent a rappelé ce matin
qu'ils allaient accélérer les contrôles
mais dans ce pays est un chômeur sur
deux qui n'est pas indemnisée il ya une
émulation moins de 900 euros et c'est
aujourd'hui la dares dit qu'il y à 13
fois plus de chômeurs que d'emplois
disponibles donc posons nous la question
de pourquoi ces jeunes reviennent par
l'emploi la qualité de l'emploi fournit
la qualité des salaires donc c'est
toujours pareil emmanuel macron fait la
chasse au chômage et non pas au choc
fait la chasse aux chômeurs pardon et
non pas au chômage donc c'est absolument
scandaleux c'est la dernière pierre à
l'édifice de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui va pour certains
allocataires se traduire par une baisse
de quasiment 40 % des gens didier
berthault pour revenir sur cette
dernière remarque on a vu on peut dire
voilà ils nous piquent nos idées et puis
son plaindre n'empêche c'est une
stratégie qui a déjà marché dans le
passé est ce que vous avez tort aux
aujourd'hui que ça refonctionne non les
électeurs sont pas des imbéciles si ça
fonctionnait il ya cinq ans et qui a eu
aucun résultat avec la france est
aujourd'hui encore plus fracturées
qu'elle ne l'était il ya cinq ans c'est
pas pour appliquer les mêmes vieilles
recettes donc aujourd'hui monsieur macro
nous explique que la sécurité est
importante jamais autant d'insécurité
nous explique que le nucléaire c'est
important il va fermer fessenheim enfin
bon un moment donné si vous voulez il
faut quand même juste lui rappeler son
bilan et puis voir qui est crédible pour
appliquer les nouvelles mesures qui
seront tournées cinq prochaines années
c'est évident a tant apporté clairement
comme la météo emmanuel macron hier il
ya la température elle et il ya le
ressenti tout au long de discours c'est
ce que vous avez pu ressentir beaucoup
de français moi je crois qu'il ya eu un
décalage entre effectivement ce que
porte emmanuel macron est le ressenti
des français dans le pays où aujourd'hui
son bilan il le traîne quelque part
comme un boulet puisqu'il ya un
mécontentement qui est extrêmement un
grand sur la sécurité notamment qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous
voilà on est dans une france plus sûre
moins de cambriolages vous génération s
quel est votre abc c'est un une
accumulation une accumulation de mesures
alors nous on a une position qui est sur
la sécurité de ne pas s'enfoncer dans le
tout sécuritaire
mais aujourd'hui emmanuel macron n'a pas
remis de police de proximité n'a pas à
redonner des moyens notamment dans les
commissariats qui sont dégradés en a
parmi ce lien et cette confiance qui
doit être établie entre la police et les
populations donc derrière les grandes
annonces des moniales mc ren on voit
qu'il ya du vent etc à emmanuel macron
parle de sécurité je rappelle quand même
une chose c'est que c'est lui qui a mis
en place une nouvelle stratégie du
maintien de l'ordre qui s'est traduit
par d'innombrables blessés y compris des
gens qui ont été tuées lors des
manifestations
donc on n'a pas de leçon à recevoir sur
la question de la sécurité de la part de
ceux priseur jean vigué berthod sur les
retraites parce que ça c'était
particulièrement voilà une campagne en
tout cas pour pour l' après 2022
on
pourra travailler plus la fin des
régimes spéciaux ça aussi ça se
rapproche de la droite vous étiez plutôt
satisfaits avec cette approche
il revient il revient aujourd'hui un
débat sur les retraites qu'on a déjà eu
il ya cinq ans qui était acté que la
droite d'ailleurs avait engagé à
plusieurs reprises sous d'autres
quinquennat il n'a pas avancé pourquoi
parce que la situation sociale est
extrêmement compliqué et qu'il a
lui-même créé cette situation sociale
conflictuelles ou alors aujourd'hui
alors oui d'accord lors fait alléger les
jaunes c'était quand même pas mal
qu'ovide un bon c'était une situation
qu'il a lui même créée aujourd'hui
revient avec le chéquier ouvert pour
distribuer les primes à droite à gauche
et puis ensuite les appliquer avec les
idées des autres honnêtement je pense
pas que le courage qu'il n'a pas eu pour
appliquer cette réforme des retraites
pendant les trois dernières années des
cinq dernières années il aura dans les
cinq prochaines
cette question des retraites on imagine
que ça aussi ça fait des générations est
évidemment puisqu'il parle de la réforme
des retraites il dit qu'il ne va pas le
mettre en place mais il dit qu'il faudra
allonger la durée de cotisation il dit
qui la mettra en place sûrement plus
tard nous on l'a toujours dit on est
opposé à cette réforme à des retraites
qui est absolument scandaleuse qui va
amener une augmentation du temps de
travail qui va baisser y compris les
pensions à la fin puis quand sortira
dans un système de solidarité tel qu'on
le connaît aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
parfait et qu'il faudra retravailler
pour qu'ils soient financés et permettre
à chacune et chacun d'avoir une retraite
décente mais en vérité on a un peu aussi
l'impression que les manuels maquereau
en jambes l'élection présidentielle et
qui nous parle comme s'il était déjà élu
et je crois que les jeux ne sont
absolument pas fait
jean didier berthault pour terminer sur
cette session à l'origine du débat ce qu
il fait campagne par la droite devant
une france justement qui se droitise en
tout cas dans les études d'opinion qui
sont quand même majoritairement qui
donne la part belle à la droite
française et ce qu'ils avaient une choix
emmanuel macron il serait suicidaire
vallée sur sa gauche mais aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il surtout il ne sait plus où
il va voilà donc on à arsène mâcon
emmanuel lupin on sait pas il a piqué le
chéquier pour le chéquier de la france
pour deux tribus et des chèques
à tire larigot depuis quelques semaines
aujourd'hui il vient piquer les idées
des candidats républicains il est paumé
c'est un président aujourd'hui qui est
paumé et un président qui est beau mais
c'est clairement quelqu'un à qui on ne
peut pas faire confiance pour l'avenir
alors autre question j'aimerais aborder
avec vous on en a peu parlé aujourd'hui
dans les médias mais c'est une petite
phrase concernant cette fois-ci la
diplomatie et la géopolitique que
président a prononcé hier écouter mais
la france ne sera pas forte seuls les
enjeux sont tels dans le choc des
puissances continentales qui se déploie
sous nos yeux que seule une entente
européenne solidaire et volontaire peut
apporter à chacun de nos pays européens
un relais et une force de frappe
il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux pour mesurer
combien nos intérêts se rencontrer
s'accordent c'est dans ce contexte du
choc des puissances américaines
chinoises russes et de déstabilisation
de nombreuses zones du monde que notre
pays aura dans deux mois la charge de
présider l'union européenne avec la
chine la russie et les etats unis dans
la même phrase c'est pas courant dans la
bouche du président de la république la
crise des sous marins australiens
emporté j'avais j'allais vous le dire
son allocution sur la partie
internationale c'est franchement la plus
ridicule la france n'a jamais été autant
affaibli sur la scène internationale et
ça me fait mal de le dire parce que
c'est notre pays mais on l'a vu avec la
crise des sous marins on l'a vu avec
l'humiliation américaine derrière on a
vu avec la crise de la pêche avec le
royaume-uni donc venir nous parler
aujourd'hui de la place de la france en
europe c'est bien on comprend bien aussi
qu'ils préparent la présidence française
de l'union européenne pendant la
campagne présidentielle ça n'a échappé à
personne mais clairement le bilan sur la
scène internationale il est aussi
désastreux et la france est affaiblie et
encore une fois je ne m'en contente pas
voilà c'est triste pour notre pays
thomas porte mais ne mettront justement
le sauveur à la tête de l'europe bientôt
il va pouvoir encore peut-être faire
campagne dans ce cadre-là contre les
ennemis des stabilisateurs ça vous
évoque quoi c'est c'est habile pour vous
la part d'un président en campagne non
je crois que c'est la politique des
petites phrases emmanuel macron nous a
habitué à ça depuis des années
d'ailleurs ces petites phrases là qui
distille qui alimente souvent les
tensions qui sont faits au travers de
déclarations de presse et qui crée après
entre plusieurs pays des tensions mais
emmanuel macron il prépare la présence
de la france à l'union européenne ce qui
est aussi un problème démocratique
puisqu'il va être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il va être président de
l'europe donc tout ça se mélange alors
qu'on ne sait pas s'il va être réélu ce
que ça va donner après donc je crois que
c'est pas sérieux d'être aujourd'hui
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
d'être président de mélanger aussi la
présence de l'europe donc tout ça fait
un enchevêtrement de mandats qu'ils
donnent à voir que finalement peut-être
que sa préoccupation principale c'est
pas celle des françaises et des français
c'est extrêmement dommage dans la
période que l'on traverse alors pour
terminer justement je me tourne
particulièrement vers vous un porte
parole de xavier bertrand qui plaide
depuis le début de sa campagne pour une
autre politique étrangère je vous
propose d'écouter votre poulain sur rtl
c'était le 19 février dernier
nous devons mettre fin à cette guerre
froide avec la russie il est urgent de
renouer un dialogue politique avec le
président us mais aussi avec le
président chinois il a fait fausse route
aussi
dire qu'il est important que la france
reprenne les rênes de son destin voilà
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné on ne
peut pas simplement se fâcher avec des
pays parce que les américains ont décidé
la france a des amis elle a des alliés
mais elle a aussi son indépendance elle
a aussi sa politique étrangère et elle
doit être souveraine dans sa politique
étrangère c'est tout le sens des propos
de xavier bertrand
merci en tout cas à tous les libéraux
merci également à vous auto m'apporte
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce décryptage
ce soir